[MUSIC PLAYING]
RISHI MALIK: Clover is a
point-of-sale device company.
We are the operating system
for small to medium businesses.
That means we make it easy for
coffee shops, for restaurants,
for retail shops to take
payments, run their business,
and deliver happiness
to their customers.
Clover's DevOps
philosophy is really
around self-service for
our engineering teams.
We want to make it as
easy as possible for all
the amazing engineers and
product managers that we have
to deliver value
to our customers
as fast as possible and with
the highest quality possible.
Like many companies, we were
encountering problems of scale.
The way we solved
that problem is
by adopting more of a
DevOps-first philosophy.
We empowered our
engineering teams
to build, deploy, and run their
code and provide the tools
and support they need to do that
effectively and, by doing that,
removed a lot of the
bottlenecks in our process,
which means we get code to
production faster, which
means we get value to
our customers faster.
And they can continue to run
their business in the way
that they need to in
the changing environment
that we're in.
What we hope to accomplish
by changing our technology
landscape is to
make sure that we
can adapt to the
changing environment
that our customers are in.
We are a company with hundreds
of engineers around the world,
millions of merchants,
and billions
of dollars that flow through
our platform in any given year.
That means what we do has
to be well orchestrated,
well planned, and well thought
out so that we do it safely
and so our customers
don't see any ill effects.
One of the great things
about working with Google
on our DevOps
transformation has been
able to utilize the experience
and, frankly, the definition
of what a lot of this is that
came through Google itself.
We were early in our journey,
and one of the challenges
that we had was educating
our entire set of engineers
and all of our teams on what
this DevOps transition and SRE
transition means for
them as individuals.
Google literally
wrote the book on SRE.
But the Google
support allowed us
to bring in Google SREs
and Google DevOps experts
to train the rest of our teams.
And that meant that we could
accomplish a lot more a lot
faster.
Having gone through this makes
me very grateful for the people
that I have around me.
Specifically, I'd love to thank
all of the engineers at Clover
for going through this
transition with us,
all of the product managers,
all of our customers.
Most importantly,
all of the people
that are really living
and breathing this,
the people who are
putting in the hours
doing documentation, the people
who are writing code and making
changes and going
above and beyond what
their normal jobs are, just
because they believe in what
we're doing, and they
know this is the best path
forward for us.
It's not a simple thing, and
it takes a lot of effort.
And I'm very
grateful for everyone
who's helped out with that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]